[Music]
this is the documentary which fully
exposed the scale of abuse in USA
Gymnastics
a toxic environment of bullying and fear
which when they're checked and now
British athletes including Olympians and
elite competitors say a similar culture
pervades the sport here one former
gymnast told me she would be regularly
beaten by her coach I thought there was
only ever one way to achieve my skill
through strict punishment and fear we
were taught to be more scared of our
coach than of the skill we were
attempting I'll never know if it was
possible to be my level without it or if
I could have been even better if I
wasn't beaten into submission
Margeaux direction was a junior GB
gymnast but was driven away from the
sport after regularly suffering abuse
and bearing witness to it no one girl
being pushed to the floor and you know
dragged off the floor by her hair
because she couldn't get kagra fee right
and then another girl where a lot of
people were in that gym at the time
being you know taken up by the leotard
and thrown and you know everybody was
watching and nobody said anything nobody
intervened
nobody said maybe this has gone too far
because you couldn't say anything I seem
to be hearing the same story over and
over again from different gymnasts
different age groups different clubs
does there need to be a complete culture
shift with British gymnastics yeah
definitely a big culture shift and it
doesn't just start with British
gymnastics it's the responsibility of
you know the clubs the coaches to
recognize that this behavior is not okay
we used to have to put a leotards up the
highest they could go for the aesthetic
basically and same thing sometimes you
know as you get older as you go through
puberty some girls prefer to wear shorts
but in some times they don't allow that
another former GB gymnast at Nottingham
Academy says athletes were so fearful
they would regularly have panic attacks
if we felt an injury during a training
session and told our coaches they would
get angry at
and sometimes throw ice aggressively in
our direction this eventually led to
many of us gymnasts just training on
injuries as we were too afraid to speak
out many of the gymnasts now have long
term injuries they will never recover
from
due to the overuse and working through
pain British gymnastics has promised to
conduct an internal investigation
admitting it's clear that gymnasts
didn't feel they could raise their
concerns to British gymnastics for many
young athletes change is long overdue
Martha Kellner Sky News